what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones update
video today I have some very exciting
news for all of us Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire junkies I have a
few different things to talk about
actually and all of them have been
confirmed now that season 7 is just a
day away HBO and other news outlets have
opened up the floodgates and revealed
all kinds of things that are going to
happen this season and beyond a few days
ago HBO held their premiere for episode
1 in Los Angeles California and although
there was a ton of security at this
event the press were still there for the
screening in to report on everything
that was taken place they obviously
aren't allowed to give away specific
plot points from the episode but they
were able to release some other details
that were just as important and
interesting a reporter from GQ magazine
was at this premiere and he has
confirmed several exciting details about
Game of Thrones I'm gonna put the link
to the full article down in the
description in case you want to read it
for yourself but make sure you stay
until the end of this video because I'm
gonna save the biggest news for last
obviously since there's gonna be tons of
information about what happened at the
premiere there are gonna be some
spoilers in this video about the first
episode so make sure you proceed with
caution if you do not want to be spoiled
the first thing that can be confirmed is
the return of our old friend in our
favorite blacksmith Gendry
the bastard son of Robert Baratheon we
have all been wondering for years if we
would ever see Gendry again after Davos
set him free from Dragonstone cells and
pushed him off in a small boat also we
have all been speculating this offseason
that Gendry would make his return in
season 7 after the trailer was released
for this season it appeared that ginjury
was back in up north of the wall with
Jon Snow and several other cast members
as you can see in the trailer there is a
group of 12 men standing in a circle in
a defensive position and one of those
men appear to be holding a war hammer
which is what Robert Baratheon was
famously known for using in battle and
killing Rhaegar Targaryen width'
Melisandre rib injury is also a
blacksmith and he has swung a hammer for
years so it makes sense for him to use a
hammer as a weapon also I guess you
could say it runs in his blood but
Gendry showed up on the red carpet
during their premiere for Game of
Thrones season 7 and one of the
reporters from GQ magazine
was also at this premiere confirmed that
Gendry would be in this season but he
said he won't make his return until
midseason I am very excited for
ginjuries return let's just hope he
stays alive long enough to reunite with
Oriya at least one last time
the reporter also said that we're used
to getting new players entering the
great game every season but Game of
Thrones is now coming close to its end
game and this enormous cast is finally
dwindling down now that we are in the
third act so we're not gonna see too
many new faces this season playing in
any kind of significant role except for
Jim Broadbent who's going to be an
unorthodox starch Meister coaching
Samwell Tarly at the Citadel and we're
going to see them together in the very
first episode I think this is some
pretty exciting news too I think most of
us did assume that this was going to
happen but now it's actually confirmed
the archmaester Marwan will have Samwell
Tarly under his wing coaching him
showing him his methods Samwell Tarly
might not actually be at the Citadel for
a very long time but I think it's safe
to say he's gonna be uncovering some
secrets and making some breakthrough
discoveries making him one of the most
important characters left now I got to
give a shout out to next from the
channel gaming theories for this next
story which came from an article written
by the Telegraph and like I said earlier
the reporters who were at the premiere
aren't able to give away too much
information about episode 1 but they did
reveal something pretty damn big without
dropping any names
they said episode 1 is going to begin
with the cold open and for those of you
that aren't familiar with what that
means a cold open is when the episode
begins without showing any of the intro
credits just like when the Hound made
his return the episode began immediately
without showing the credits that way he
didn't see the actor's name beforehand
which would have gave away that he was
back and they're gonna do the same thing
this season in the first episode and I
think that's because Walder Frey's
coming back although he is dead David
Bradley was recasted for this season and
it has to be because Arya is gonna be
wearing his face listen and what this
reporter said about the cold opening in
episode 1 he said the episode opens with
the cold open they got a huge audience
reaction it involved the notorious
plotter addressing his followers then a
shift in tone in a swift massacre
without any actual violence in a
dramatic unveiling which prompted wild
applause in gleeful Cheers
Walder Frey is definitely a notorious
plotter and it said that there was a
swift massacre but there was no violence
that sounds like they were poisoned
aurilla definitely knows a thing or two
about poison from her time spent at the
house of black and white and then it
says a dramatic unveiling which means
arya is gonna take off Walder Frey's
face and that's why the crowd reacted
like the way they did this is gonna be
pretty damn insane for an opening scene
the episode is gonna start with Oreo
wearing water phrase face and massacring
everyone there all I can really say is
Wow
but you know what's interesting about
this this was actually leaked all the
way back in November having killed
Walder Frey Arya uses his face to summon
the rest of the phrase to his shindig
after she sends all the woman out of the
room arya proposes a toast and she
poisons all of them in one go
now that sounds exactly like what that
article just said happened when they
screened the premiere I think we can
expect to see this happen too but let's
get to the most exciting news of all
which was also revealed during the
premiere of Game of Thrones season 7
episode 1 and I'm sure most of you by
now know that HBO has been in the
process of trying to come up with a new
spin-off show based within the world of
A Song of Ice and Fire
after Game of Thrones is over Game of
Thrones is one of the most popular and
successful shows in the history of
television and everyone at HBO wants to
keep this train moving full steam ahead
since george RR martin created such a
huge universe there is a number of
directions they could go with the new
show after Game of Thrones ends in about
a month ago george RR martin himself
released a statement about the status of
the spin-off shows that were currently
in development George said HBO hired
five new writers who were all going to
create their own story based off a
Georgia story then they're gonna turn
these five scripts into pilots and hope
and pray one of them got picked up and
turned into HBO's next smash hit but if
you know anything about how television
works things don't always go as planned
just because you hire all these writers
to make pilots doesn't necessarily mean
any of them are going to get turned into
TV shows but we have some great news too
this is amazing news actually HBO has
confirmed at least one spin-off show is
coming after season 8 ends next year
this is absolutely incredible news for
all of us that didn't want this to end
we are definitely going to get more of
George's story to experience on
television HBO confirmed that we are
getting one new show after season eight
ends next year but they also said we
might get more than one but one for
Shore comment down below and tell me
what show you think we're gonna what you
think about all of this down below and
I'll see you in the comment section bye